[Music]
in this video we'll show you how you can
predict
user churn for your gaming apps using
google analytics 4
and bigquery ml my name is polong lin
and i'm a developer advocate for google
cloud
i'm minhas kazi and i'm a developer
advocate for google analytics
if you're a mobile game developer a
potential challenge for you could be
user pretension
with so many games and apps to choose
from keeping users
interested in your product and enabling
them to come back can be really
difficult
according to a study in 2019 most mobile
gamers
see only a 25 retention for users
after 24 hours that means on average
three out of four users will churn
they'll first use their app
and then after a day they'll stop
playing so the question is
if i'm a mobile game developer how do i
reduce
churn hold on you have experience with
machine learning
can that help here absolutely at a high
level
you can use machine learning to predict
which of your users are going to churn
based on how they're behaving in the app
and their demographic information
once you have the predictions of who's
likely to churn you can then target
those users who are perhaps
on the fence to incentivize them to come
back to the app or game
or make the game just a bit more
rewarding for them to play
predicting each user's propensity to
churn that's where machine learning can
help us
user's propensity to churn that sounds
interesting
maybe we can apply this to real life
example we have this mobile game called
flooded
that's available both on the app store
and google play store
can we identify user's propensity to
churn for that app
certainly as long as you have the
behavioral data
you can build machine learning models to
predict user propensity
to perform any specific behavior like
churn or
making in-app purchases or sharing the
game with a friend
just as examples okay so here's the
scenario
we have this flooded app and we can use
usage data from there
my goal is to identify specific users
who are likely to churn
and then try to retain them i can for
example
through firebase 10 notifications to
these users
or customize the game to be extra
rewarding to them
through google analytics i can segment
the users and analyze different
likelihoods of
churn and do marketing campaigns
or through other marketing tools tied
together with email or other marketing
campaigns
so poland how would i use machine
learning to do this
hold on there are a couple of steps in
order to get to these activation
scenarios
let's walk through all the required
steps in reverse order
so you just talked about the last step
which is using the predictions
for activation in order for that to
happen you'll need a churn prediction
model
to give you these predictions on each
user's likelihood
or probability to churn and you can
build this machine learning model using
bigquery ml
but to create this model you'll need to
first have prepare the data in the right
format
for the machine learning model so we
call this step data preprocessing which
is done in bigquery so that brings us to
the first step which is making sure you
have your data ready in bigquery
great that fits in nicely since we can
use google analytics 4
to measure usage data for the flooded
app we can just export that usage data
into bigquery
minhas could you tell us a little bit
about google analytics 4
if you're not already familiar google
analytics 4
or ga4 is the newest edition of google
analytics
it allows you to measure user engagement
not just for websites
but also for apps ga4 uses an
event-based model
usually when the user or the app does
something that's an event
if you're an app developer who's already
been using google analytics for firebase
you can be rest assured that it's the
same data model as year 4.
what's new with google analytics 4 is
that any user
free or paid can now export the jio4
event data into bigquery
and exporting data to bigquery is really
interesting because with bigquery which
is the data warehouse on google cloud
you can analyze terabytes of data in
seconds and you can also train
and deploy machine learning models as
you'll learn in this video
so if you're a marketing analyst you can
train and deploy machine learning models
just by writing sql
without any additional programming
languages so min has
how would a google analytics user export
their data to bigquery
i can log on to the google analytics for
property and go to the admin section
then click on bigquery linking
on the right hand side we will see that
for this property
no link has been created to bigquery so
you can click on link
then it will ask for which bigquery or
google cloud platform project
to link it to if you haven't used
bigquery before
at this point you'll just need to set up
an account on google cloud platform
and select the appropriate project we'll
select our project
and then click next for our analysis
we'll use the daily export
after you've reviewed and submitted your
export options
ga4 will start exporting the event data
for this property
to select a bigquery project after a day
or two
you should start seeing the daily even
data in the events table
in the bigquery ui we can click on the
preview tab
and it will show us what the even export
data looks like
each row is a unique event that occurred
at a specific timestamp
you also get the event name and
additional information about the event
in even parameters for example in the
first row
it looks like the event was a level
complete quick play by the user
so now that we have our g8 and bigquery
hold on
what's our next step well in order for
the machine learning algorithm to train
the model properly
we need to pre-process the raw ga4 data
to be in the right format
this is an example of what an ideal
format might look like for the training
data
specifically every row needs to be
represented by a single user
along with a label of churned one or
zero
we also want to include features that
can help the model learn
specifically the user's demographic
information and
any sort of behavioral data such as the
number of times they open the app
within a certain time period so the way
this works
in this data pre-processing stage is
first
we'll need to identify users and the
churned label
process demographic features and process
behavioral features
then we'll combine them together as the
training data
with the training data ready we can then
move on to building the churn prediction
model
so the first step is making sure we have
a solid definition of churn
now your definition of churn may vary
here you may want to predict churn after
one day one week or simply whether or
not they will turn after the first
30 minutes of installing the app that
definition is entirely up to you to
decide
what makes sense for your app for us we
chose to define churn as the following
after 24 hours of a user's first
engagement with the app the users who
never came back
we call churned those who come back
after 24 hours
we can say they returned that means
given all the user data that we have
we want to say based on the user
information within the first 24 hours of
them using the app
can we predict if they will turn or
return
but hold on what about those users who
use the app
and then within just a few minutes they
decide that it's not that for them at
all
perhaps those users aren't worth
targeting with any sort of incentives
because this wasn't something they were
looking for
i would prefer to exclude them that's a
good point
let's ignore users who left the app
within the first 10 minutes
we'll call these bounced users so when
we build the machine learning model
we'll only look at users who didn't
bounce
so prediction model will be based only
on the users who spend at least 10
minutes
on the app to prepare the user data in
bigquery first we'll create a bounced
label column engagement is an event when
the user interacts with the app
if the user's last engagement was within
10 minutes of their first engagement
we'll consider that the users have
bounced
balanced users will get labeled with a
one in the bounced column
otherwise the value is zero for all
unbalanced users
next we'll create a label column for
churned
so if the user's last engagement was
within 24 hours of their first
engagement
we will consider the user to have
churned otherwise we know that
they did something with the app after
the first 24 hours
meaning that they did not turn so we
give those users a value of churn equals
zero
so this is what it looks like now one
label for churn
and one label for balanced perfect so in
the next section we want to process the
demographic information
available for each user minhas can you
explain what demographic data is
available in the ga4 data
in ga events export some demographic
data about the user is reported
automatically
like the device language and operating
system user's browser
and geographic information you can also
use user parameters in j4 to capture
additional user demographic data
for simplicity we only chose country
operating system
and the user's device language and here
if there are multiple rows per user like
if they were in different countries
then you can just use perhaps the most
recent demographic information
to have only one row per user
okay so the next step is preparing the
behavioral data
and this step is really important
because you want to help the machine
learning model learn how the user's
behavior
in those first 24 hours predict whether
or not they churn
min has what sort of behavioral data
does ga4 capture
and what fields will you consider using
as we mentioned before each row in ga4
data is an event
some events are automatically captured
by gf4
there are recommended events for
specific use cases like gaming
you can also create custom events
depending on your app
let's see what type of events we have in
the flooded data set
we'll query all the event names and sort
by their account
across the data set as you can see
there are automatically collected events
like screen view and
user engagement the other events are
recommended events for gaming
like level start quickplay and postscore
from the list we chose this subset of
events
to be most important for our analysis
but you can choose whichever events you
think
might help the ml model determine who is
likely to churn
for your app so we like this sort of
result
where each row is a unique user id and
for each user
we have some behavioral stats like how
many times they engage with the app
how many times they started a level with
quick play or
ended a level with quick play and so on
we can achieve this by counting
different events in different columns
for each user
now that we've prepared our label the
demographic data
and behavioral data we can combine them
into a single table which becomes our
training data
a quick side note before moving on to
machine learning
let's assume that you have other
demographic or behavioral data from
outside of ga
that you want to use for example the
data could be in your crm you can import
that data into bigquery
and then join them using the user id and
use that for training as well
so with the training data ready now we
can finally talk about building the
machine learning model to predict
churn using bigquery ml
in this section we'll be using bigquery
ml to train the
churn prediction model evaluate the
model
and make predictions on new users to get
their probability of churning
if you're not familiar with what
bigquery ml is it's the
ml or machine learning functionality
that's built into bigquery by default
so if your data is stored in bigquery
without needing to move it out you can
use bigquery ml to train and deploy
machine learning models directly using
sql you don't need to know
python r or tensorflow you also don't
need to set up any extra infrastructure
because it uses
bigquery's auto scaling infrastructure
to train and deploy your
ml models so that means you get your
data storage data analytics and machine
learning all built into bigquery
there are lots of different machine
learning model types available with
bigquery ml
for propensity modeling you'll want to
use one of these supported
classification models
to keep things simple we'll stick with
logistic regression in this video as
it's typically the fastest
to train you can always try to improve
your models afterwards but this gets you
to a working model quickly
so to train a logistic regression model
using sql first
you'll need your training data select
star from the table you just
put together next you'll want to create
workplace model
followed by the project and data set and
the name of the model
which we've chosen here to be turn lodge
reg next we'll need to specify that we
want to use logistic regression
as well as setting the churned column to
be the target variable we want to
predict
and that's all you need and once the
model is trained you can evaluate
it in bigquery ml and to do so you can
use the bigquery ui which
shows you the evaluation metrics when
you select the model you've trained
you can see the metrics like log loss
roc oc
precision recall accuracy f1 score and
some visualizations
you can also evaluate the model using
select star from
ml.evaluate and then the model name
if you create multiple models you can
use something like roc auc
or f1 score to compare your models with
better models having scores closer to
1.0
and depending on your needs this is
where you could be iterating between
training the model and evaluating the
model to try to improve your model
performance
there are various approaches to
improving models you can try a
different model type such as boosted
tree classifier
deep neural networks or even automl
tables all
which are supported in bigquery ml you
can also try to select different
features
or more features or engineer new
features out of existing ones
and of course you can also try tuning
some of the hyper parameters of your
models
to learn more check out the
documentation
great so now with the model created how
do we make predictions on
who might actually churn or return
you can use select star from ml.predict
followed by the model
and the data you want to make
predictions on note that for the test
data
it should have the same columns as you
had in the training data
we can see what the model predicted in
the first column
but this isn't actually what we are
looking for for propensity modeling we
actually want a probability
of how likely someone is to churn some
value between zero
and one so for this we'll need to
extract out the probability from the
third column called
predictedchurnedprobs.prop for when
the label is equal to 1.
to do so you can extract the probability
of churn for each user
using this sql query
now that we have the user's propensity
to churn
how do you use these predictions for
activation minhas
to get the data into a usable state
we can either read it directly from
bigquery
or export it into google cloud storage
or gcs
as csv files this query will
export the selected columns into a csv
file in a gcs bucket
we can use either the bigquery data or
the exported csv file
in different ways depending on how then
tool works for example firebase can
directly import from bigquery
whereas external marketing tools might
need to use csv files
in ga4 you can use the data import
feature
to import the predicted values as a user
property
then the user property can be used to
create segments
and remarketing lists if you're using
firebase for your app
you can also import the predictions back
into firebase to tailor the user
experience using remote config
or send notifications to the user using
cloud messaging
and in-app messaging you might also use
other external tools to run marketing
campaigns like sending out emails to
motivate users to return
using the steps described in this video
we should be able to do the activations
and finally increase the number of users
retained for the flooded app
and reduce the number of users churned
great
so to recap we showed you how to export
your ga4 data
into bigquery how to pre-process the
churn label
demographic data and behavioral data to
get the training data in a proper format
in bigquery then we talked about how to
train evaluate and make predictions
using bigquery ml
and finally we covered a few ways to use
the predictions
for activations if you'd like to follow
the steps you can check out the blog
post or the github notebook
by going to the links in the video
description below
thanks for watching